c'est une phrase à laquelle les gérants
de bars espérer échapper hier la fin de
soirée résonnait bien moins fort que
d'habitude dans la célèbre rue
saint-michel surnommé rue de la soif en
raison du nombre de troquer qu'elle
accueille
sommée de fermer leur établissement à
23h jusqu'au 30 septembre afin de
limiter la propagation grandissante du
coït 19 dans la ville les tenanciers ont
la gueule de bois
déjà durement frappée par le confinement
certains y voient un coup de grâce selon
le président de l'union des métiers et
des industries de l'hôtellerie
d'ille-et-vilaine telle annonce de la
mesure hier on a eu plus de 120 appels à
l'umih d'ille-et-vilaine de gens qui
sont désespérés qui disent on fait 20 à
30% de chiffre d'affaires entre entre 11
heures et une heure du matin
c'est le coup de grâce
donc
on est en train de regarder comment
comment on pourrait faire infléchir la
préfecture
dans cette ville où les étudiants sont
présents en masse les pertes s'annonce
colossale la décision passe mal pour
certains établissements ouverts jusqu'à
une heure ou trois heures du matin en
temps normal de nombreux patrons
dénoncent l'inefficacité de la mesure
c'est ce qui va se passer c'est que
laissera ils vont se faire dans des
appartements d'étudiants vous avez déjà
vu une chambre étudiants ce que c'est un
17 mètres carrés quand ils vont être 30
ou 40 à blanc il y aura pas d'agents de
sécurité y aura par la police on est
allé contrôler il y aura pas de port de
masques dimanche l' agence régionale de
santé a relevé 43 nouvelles
contaminations à l'université rennes 1 1
kloster qui va obliger près de 500
étudiants à se faire tester l'analyse
avancée par l'agent sanitaire pour
expliquer ce foyer de contamination sont
les nombreuses soirées d'intégration
étudiante organisée en cette rentrée
universitaire dans des bars